تحديات الحرب في اوكرانيا كثيره بسبب
اصرار موسكو على تدمير بنيتها التحتيه
ابرزها بالنسبه للاكرانيين الكهرباء
والماء مع دخول فصل الشتاء قارس في
العاصمه كيف التي لم تتوقف روسيا عن
استهدافها يسعى مالك مقهى الى توفير شيء
من الدفئ والضوء لزبائنه وما تيسر من
خدمات
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي وعدم توفر خدمه
الانترنت
المشهد في المقاهي يقابله اخر في بعض
المطاعم والمنازل يعول من خلاله
الاوكرانيين على مولدات الكهرباء للحصول
على الطاقه
على 10 ساعات مع توفر البنزين تساعدنا على
تقديم الشاي والقهوه
الخدمات في المقاهي وان كانت بسيطه لكنها
تساعد كثيرين في الحصول على خدمات
الانترنت بينهم طلاب الجامعات مما يفتقدون
وسائل الراحه في منازلهم
وتحتاج الى انجازها وتقديمها باسرع وقت
بالاضافه الى الدراسه لذلك اتردد على
المقهى
ومع استمرار روسيا في استهداف مواقع
الطاقه الاوكرانيه واتهام كيبلي موسكو
باستهداف المدنيين وحرمانهم من الكهرباء
والماء اصبح المشهد والمعتاد في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه تعلوه اصوات المولدات ورائحه
البنزين رغم شرحه لدفع عجله الحياه
اليوميه
جاسم محسن العربيه